el fuego no da tregua en el noroeste de
Argentina casi un 10% de la superficie
de la provincia de corrientes quedó
arrastrada por las llamas que amenazan
la fauna y flora del parque natural de
iberá El mayor humedad del país la
intensidad del fuego que se fue
repartiendo lo mismo que ha pasado en
otros lugares
hoy y el 9% de la provincia está en la
misma situación y realmente Una
provincia verde llena de agua hoy la
estamos defendiendo de la intensa sequía
mientras los bomberos llevan semanas
luchando para crear los incendios que se
están grabando por las sequías
consecuencias según los expertos de la
crisis climática lo que supone un duro
golpe para la economía de esta región
rural Argentina
Paraguay debido a las casas de lluvia
en promedio anuales no no en nuestros
pasto no no no no crecen Entonces por es
del animal tiene poco alimento por el de
cae la producción ahí baja de ternero
los novillos no engordan lo suficiente Y
así sucesivamente verdad
de calor extremo continuará la próxima
semana y solo se prevén precipitaciones
ocasionales